[Music]
demi lovato just dropped her new music
video for I love me and not only is it a
10 out of 10 but it's freaking packed
with Easter eggs referencing major
moments from her past the video kicks
off with a pretty clear message Demi is
fighting off the darker side of herself
and frankly the new strong confident
Demi is kicking old Demi's ass
yes Demi yes
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's when she hits us with the
first hidden gem it comes at you pretty
fast so don't blink or you might just
miss it rewind and Potts yep right there
fans were quick to point out that those
little girls with their mom are pretty
solid look-alikes of Demi
her sister Dallas and her mama Diana
then there's this
[Applause]
[Music]
that's Demi walking right past what
looks like her and Nick Jonas from their
Camp Rock days they drown these brothers
I've said a million times they're
awesome and working with them is like
working with you know your friends it's
cool then she strolls right on by three
grown-up Jonas Brothers look-alikes the
glow up is real yeah it's hard to miss
that one of course the Jonas Brothers
have played a pretty big part in her
career and personal life over the years
Demi and the boys go way back to those
camp rock days
Demi even briefly dated Joe Jonas back
in 2010
Demi then seems to reference her 2018
overdose when she passes an ambulance
and reaches out to a woman being carried
off on a stretcher
[Music]
and last but not least there's this
[Music]
slow it way down and you'll see a bride
and groom running right past Demi fans
were quick to speculate that the groom
represents Demi's ex will'd or
Valderrama who she dated from 2010 to
2016 Wilmer got engaged in January to
model Amanda Pacheco and not gonna lie
that really does look like Wilmer the
former couple has remained close over
the years Wilmer even visited Demi in
the hospital after her overdose we've
been in each other's lives for her
entire journey you know so so - Syria
ball but such a multi-faceted artist to
me it is really you know what people
needed to see so I'm very proud of her
but from the looks of this music video
Demi's cool with Wilmer moving on
because she's got herself love to get
her through
well I know what I'm gonna be singing
all weekend long of course you can count
on et to bring you all the latest on
demi so keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens and
remember you're a ten out of ten